today i will be writing four raps in one
hour 10 minutes one minute
and 10 seconds don't freeze on me now
it's literally just
words oh what the [ __ ]
that's the noise i make
one minute to write a wrap i'm going to
use suggestions that you guys mailed to
me
uh in in envelopes this is what our rap
is going to be about
throwing around what the [ __ ] is that
flight of the navigator
movie fine okay this is a minute long
rap about the flight of the navigator
um how to rhyme
about flick that you ain't
ever seen i much prefer
the great escape this is just a poem
with steve
my bloody queen
it's not the aviator
with leo as
howard hughes that doesn't scan
it's got emotion it's
got poise but it didn't
make the news
i'll watch it one day
in the future watch
that movie later and then
i'll write a real rap
about flight of i can't do the scanning
this is
my meter's right off
fly my pretties there we go
yeah we did it i'm gonna record this and
perform it uh as i've written
so um i hope you enjoy that
hard to rhyme about a flick that you
ain't never seen i much prefer the
greatest state with steven bloody queen
it's not the aviator william is how it's
used it's got emotion it's got voice but
didn't make the news i'll watch you one
day in the future watch the movie later
and then i'll write a real rapper like a
navigator
fly my pretties make sure you click the
like button if we get over 10 000 likes
i will do this again
even though it is incredibly stressful
i'm gonna take another suggestion
hopefully it is one that i
understand this time topic is about leo
the zodiac sign oh we mentioned leo and
the last one that's cool
leo the zodiac sign okay i put 11
seconds of time because that swipe takes
up time
let's um this is annoying okay
um egypt ferro
queen called cleo renault
cleo i i'm a leo
oh what the [ __ ] that's no
time at all
oh [ __ ] off it's literally just words
a renault clio is the car i remember my
mum having for most of my childhood
it was gold gold car imagine that no
wonder i grew up to be a rapper
this is what that song sounds like
[Music]
now we're at the 10 minute wrap i'm
gonna open up a new
envelope of suggestions this one comes
from france oh
very fancy that french stamp let's uh
open this up this is what it's going to
be about
i think this is just a letter here are
my suggestions
have fun these are the suggestions i
don't know which one to take
for a song i want more emotion to it so
sleeping under the sofa
because your girlfriend's on one of
those days i'm gonna use a beat for this
one maybe this is good
yeah i like that i'm gonna keep that
looping in the background
okay let's start that timer a rap
written in 10 minutes about sleeping
under the sofa because your girlfriend's
one of those days
okay um name for the girlfriend i'll
pick my wife she's called alice no you
can't start with like alice a flyer lady
you might know her but she got mad at me
sleeping under the sofa you need to ease
up to that that's that's not good enough
i mean i've wasted a minute already
it's far from pleased oh look at these
fun rhyme beasts least i'm pleased we're
nailing this good nice and turn around
there please cheese cheese off you could
say
oh [ __ ] i mean these are some obvious
right breed me and c
and i can see she's in
one of those moods you know what i'm
talking about dudes
yeah come on misogyny you know what i'm
talking
about dudes did i do wrong so that's
what we're trying to dig into the actual
kind of theory behind it
what did you do wrong uh leave the seat
on the loo we're gonna split this over
two lines leave the seat
on the louis of the toilet by the way in
the uk
up and not
down provoking
the frowns i don't want to reuse down
how much time we got [ __ ]
down down in france i [ __ ] hate
myself no
nookie haven't used the word nookie
since i used to like lip biscuit
no nookie for me i gotta sleep
by myself let's just listen how these
scans so far it's pretty good that's
pretty good
um okay okay so i mean something maybe
about this
maybe we'll fix that later um don't
freeze on me now
don't freeze on me now what are you
doing i'm right in a wreck in 10 minutes
mate
you're a macbook pro you made a work
right plan b plan b
go to the notes app go to the notes app
quick quick
open up you [ __ ] [ __ ] off
oh it's worked now fine i should get an
extra 30 seconds for that
okay hoping that i can slouch i mean
that's fine
how many how much time [ __ ] we're
halfway through cushions yeah because
then i can use pillows later cushions
and throws because you don't want to
repeat stuff if you don't have to nap
them with the cushions upon the surface
napping with the cushions and throws
nestling oh what nestling is nice nice
word
[ __ ] that's nest lighting that's when
you give milk formula to people in
africa and
uh commit human rights violations i'm
burrowing under yes because we're
getting under the couch
i'm borrowing under uh
with oh this is good what's under the
caps this is imagery right this is what
right with the dust
bunnies um oh lost pennies
dust bunnies lost pennies kind of works
um you could say rusty pennies but
that's as an extra syllable all of the
fluff
old remote batteries
um forgotten stuff oh that meter doesn't
work forgotten we're not forgotten but
forgotten stuff
um okay hook how long um how's the hook
gonna work on this
i'm under under the sofa i'm
under there i'm under
under the sofa cause she don't care
yeah okay okay okay we got
minute 45. let's just try and just kind
of perfect this a bit
um i mean i'm gonna have to go this
quick uh
um oh no no no [ __ ] that [ __ ] that it
doesn't matter
let's give it a kind of conclusion but
i'm not in there
who's hos yeah that's a subliminal
freudian
she proffers proffers no offers offers
profits is so [ __ ] victorian uh she
oh this is so gross as she slips her
hand
down between my thighs
because i've got a vagina um i sit down
down between my thighs
i smile i cry
as i quickly arrive he's coming
and i come under the sofa
where the oh geez
no why have i ended it like this why
have i ended it like that
oh [ __ ] off i can't change it now
[ __ ] time's up it's not bad
it's not bad but that doesn't mean it's
good
[Music]
relationships are fickle beasts to say
the least sometimes your lady is far
from pleased
cheesed off you could say turning to
bree so she turns to me
and then i can see she's in one of those
moods you know what i'm talking about
dudes what did i do wrong leave the seat
on the loo
up and not down provoking the frowns or
not tidy the lounge when her friends
came round
either way or something else i know it
can't be helped no nookie for me i gotta
sleep by myself
so i head to the couch hoping that i'm
allowed hoping that she will vouch
hoping that i can slouch upon the
surface napping with the cushions and
trolls
nestling amongst the blankets head upon
the pillows but i spy
from my eye a face like thunder so i
pull out the couch and i'm burrowing
under with the dust bunnies lost pennies
all at the fluff
old remote batteries forgotten stuff
still
i suppose it's better than sleeping
rough got a whole five foot but it's
never enough
i'm under under the sofa
i'm under there i'm under
[Music]
she don't care what a guy do wrong
i ain't aware i got a bed king size long
but i'm not in there the next day i
awake and i rub my eyes
i turn to my right and to my surprise
who's that right by me
who's beside is my lovely lover it's my
soon to be bright
she offers her lips to apologize as she
slips her hand down
between my thighs i smile i cry as i
quickly arrive and i'll come under the
sofa where the jizz can hide
i have put all these tracks together
into an ep called time crisis which is a
dumb pun but this is a dumb challenge
you can go and listen to all of those
right now on spotify
or you can pay what you want for it on
bandcamp the links are in the
description
we've now come to the most challenging
part writing one
wrap in one hour hopefully it's going to
be
six times as good as the 10 minute one i
don't know if that's how it's going to
work
yes i like this one perusing power tools
on a visit to b and q
bnq is a hardware store we'll give it a
go this is probably gonna turn out
terribly [ __ ] [ __ ]
i have a beat that i know i want to use
this is the beat it's heavy
juxtapose nicely with this kind of dumb
thing i guess we just start by spaffing
down things
is there more than drills what are the
power tools i know you have hammer
drills right there
an angle grinder oh wait start the timer
why didn't you [ __ ] start your piece
of [ __ ] guess we're writing a song in
one hour and two minutes power tools
very
masculine very manly looking at power
tools when you're being cute
is this like it's like when you go to a
store to play a guitar that you're not
going to buy you're just playing this
guitar that you might not be able to get
so maybe this is like
it's like pornography sorenography
come on someone who wanks off while
watching horror films this is a double
decaffeinated session i have a
decaffeinated tea and a decaffeinated
coke zero
no stimulation in there just cancer
rather than the ten minute wrap where i
just started writing lines with this i'm
going to try and just put some ideas
down
what's the hook is this a hook or is
this a title
this is not a drill thrills spills
chills because they're arousing license
to drill oh wait this is [ __ ] great
i'm in heaven
i got a license to drill
yeah baby okay eight minutes gone i'm
technically like 10.
i just like the idea of someone wrapping
a whole [ __ ] aisle of tools
i love tools i love tools
aisle of tools
that's a noise i make this song is just
going to be four lines i love tools if
you don't then you
fool yeah they'll teach you about the
[ __ ] in school they're real cool
why because i love tools they make me
salivate yeah they're making me drool
i'm not feeling good about that lukewarm
tea lukewarm weird phrase
no other male names like that yeah i'm
sebastian hot
tough skin rough chin there we go
because i don't have a tough chin
but it can be rough if i haven't shaved
for about two weeks
building up to like where the song is
going to really blow up which is when
we're talking about the power tools
this is nice i like how both of these
the rhyme from the final line of the
cent the one before it is leading into
the next verse
and then that rhyme screen goes so we
got i'm a big buff dude i'm tough too
and then someone's like
not far so you're having a laugh keep it
safe in the garage never parked outside
i think i'm just rapping about my dad
here i'll go on my charms
chums means friends i use the term
charms a lot people who join the channel
you're called chums
although because you pronounce chris
with a ch but like it's k
then that would make you chris's [ __ ]
which is
troubling imagine if every word that
began with ch was pronounced like chris
it'd be like would you like a lovely bar
of dark cocklet
[ __ ] why did i say dark cockler
could have said milk cockler but no not
speaking too soon guys but
this could actually not be [ __ ] maybe
it's gonna be like this is not a drill
it's a circular saw and then it will
just go it's an angle grinder it's just
gonna be a wrap out power tools this is
[ __ ] i'm so happy pause because i
love
tools [ __ ] windy outside calm down
you prick
there we go a little chorus for me this
is the scariest one the 10 second one
oh stressful oh minute one stressful but
this one has to be good because it's had
that time put into it you know
yeah i like this just repeating that
first line
it might not be funny but it's fun this
is not a drill with a hose trimmer
oh this is a dumb rhyme if you can guess
what i'm putting take it to the garden
make the hedge thinner oh
oh just thought of a rhyme i mean look
at that guy
shave it all down like you bringer this
is not a drill it's a cordless drill
when you put it in the wall get
sword the spill oh yes yes
final couple of verses then fine tooth
comb make it good
let's just run through this because this
feels like it's good
[Music]
i'm glad i went through because i was
missing a line in one place the chorus
needs an extra thing each time
see if we can add some extra chorus
that'll be the cherry on the cake
i want to do a wesley sniper joke
anything with the blades automatically
cool i mean this is very patriarchal
like men love tools
sure there are women who love tools as
well
she loves my tool i think we've done it
and i feel like that extra minute i had
at the start because the timer
is redundant now because we've got it i
can't think of a better line than this
one
and that's probably not enough time i
used a hacksaw to
cut my umbilical
cord this is probably better since i was
a kid i adored i'd use a hacksaw to cut
my umbilical cord yes that's good
i think we've done it i think we've
[ __ ] done it
that's the end [ __ ] yeah ah
enjoy this rap
this is not a drill i repeat
this is not a drill
i'm a block i'm a man i'm a massive lad
so masculine it's like i've got two
dance brute strengths real hench don't
misconstrue
tough skin rough chin i'm a big buff
dude and i'm tough too
you all understand got a 20 20-year
mortgage i own land
my home is in the castle my home is
behalf i'm a man so i take showers
not baths so you're having a laugh i
take pride in my ride keep it safe in
the garage never part outside
clean it each week with a soap and a
sponge but the real truth save for the
end of the month i don't go in my charms
spend time with myself
drive out to the retail park in my elf
for a mayo
a routine's gotta be kept an appointment
near my juliettes i mean plural yes
now i'm teasing you so i'll kiss and
tell i'm in bnq
that's a hardware store for the public
and trade i arrive at nine and i spend
the day
when i'm there i stay in a specific
section got a wide selection
of art collection i'm a man just wanted
to be sure to mention
so much power giving me an erection
cause i love tools so i'm in the isle of
tools
chainsaws leaf blowers making me draw i
love tools so much i might buy a van
and start a new life as a handyman i
love tools so i'm in the aisle of tools
anything with the blades automatically
cool i love tools
this is my heaven i got a license to
drill like double o
seven this is not a drill it's a
circular saw cut planks into pieces put
holes in the floor
just press a little button here the
pretty thing raw cause this is not a
drill it's a circular saw
this is not a drill it's an angle
grinder when you see sparks fly it's a
nice reminder
this one swish cause it's tipped with
diamonds this is not a drill it's an
angle grinder this is not a drill it's a
hedge trimmer
take it out to the yard make the hedge
thinner shave it all down like you'll
bring up
cause this is not a drill it's a hedge
trimmer this is not a drill it's a
cordless drill
put it to the wall let's sword i spill
spin like hurricanes hitting dutch mills
cause
this is not a drill it's a cordless trip
i want power in the palm of me and like
all men i want a thing with a maxed out
rpm
batteries plugged in doesn't matter the
vaults love a black and decker john
deere even do all i love to buy
i love to browse i love to take it home
and get to work in my house i'm addicted
to peruse and i always want more looking
at the top shelf like diy because i love
tools so i'm in the i love tools
salivate to my shirts covered in drool i
love tools since i was a kid i adored i
used a hacksaw to cut off my umbilical
cord i love tools
so i'm in the i love tools some of them
are sharp you gotta follow the rules i
love
tools and if you wanna guess why it's
cause my chromosomes are x y
this has been one of the hardest things
i've ever had to do in terms of rap
so please do leave a like a comment
about which your favorite rap was
and again click that like and we'll do
this video again you can check out all
these tracks on spotify
go there follow my profile listen to all
my new music i'm putting out
[Music]
egypt pharaoh
you